you mentioned your kids a second ago uh
and they're getting to the age where
they can appreciate you now this is
this is odd when you uh
were were up against the giants your son
was not rooting for you rooting for eli
manning odell beckham jr is that true
yes that's true well that's your son's
right and this is you're about to go out
and play
and he's saying i hope you lose
all right and they win yeah
and this this is our oldest son bailin
who's seven now he was the one who
i i held up at the super bowl so this is
how he repays me but
um i remember that's an iconic moment
you held him up with a super bowl and
he's bathed in the light of your glory
and now he's a few years it's a few
years later and he's saying
i hope you lose
how quickly they turn on you yeah you
know what's the explanation
well so he he actually loyal to a fault
he
he goes to uh newman school in new
orleans
which is the same school attended by eli
manning and odell beckham
so he chose his school over you that's
right
the the green and white run runs deeper
than than
than the blood obviously that's not
right
to take it a step further so i get home
after we play the texans this year
and um you know j.j watt kind of had his
way with us sacked me a few times and i
walk in the door kind of battered
bruised frustrated but then i see the
kids and i'm just waiting for that
moment just to embrace them and
man been a long day and the minute i hug
him
they they say dad let's let's let's play
football and i'm like all right let's do
whatever you guys want to do let's go
and they say okay
you be drew brees and
i can do that and we'll be
j.j watt and you stand there
and we're gonna hit you
and you just keep going down i just kept
going down what a fun house to come home
to yeah
there's never a dull moment that's
terrible all right
you didn't you tweeted that you dared a
son of yours to pull his tooth out is
that right that was also bailing the
oldest
yeah he's kind of the guinea pig with a
lot of things um
well first of all you said he's seven
because when i first heard the tweet i
thought
maybe he's like 22. like
kid pull your tooth out he's asking for
more money and i'm telling you you got
to pull your tooth out before you get it
now he's
he was c6 and so we're sitting there
just reading a bedtime story and i see
him kind of fiddling with his tooth and
i said hey let me see that and it's it's
pretty loose
he's like oh it hurts and i said i tell
you what bud by the time i'm finished
reading this book
if you have that tooth pulled out i'll
get you that lego set that you've been
wanting he's big into legos right now
and
i think he wanted a certain lego set i
said i'll get you that lego set if you
pull that tooth out
just to see if he would do it
i mean sometimes you just got to try
these things right just kind of
i wonder why he roots for other i know
exactly right so did it so what did he
do
he just yanked it out so we're sitting
there and i get a little bit further in
the book and all of a sudden
i i see him just go i did it
and he's got the tooth in his hand there
and there's blood trickling down his
chin
it was one of my prouder yeah he was
like i did it you went i still see more
teeth in your head